hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of erisa fury i'm kelsey cook
and today i'm joined by hilarious
comedian Jon Heffron everybody yeah
right I'm so happy you're here
I'm excited I'm excited you did this yes
follow through young lady this is the
first foosballs that i say oh yeah it's
first table that I've seen since I was a
little kid behind uh we had Matchbox
cars in the gold at my house it was kind
of like like ours in our basement was
that like cash house for any contraband
would go actually in there is literally
nobody played it just looked like a
permanent garage sale in your basement
yeah that's fine
oh good telling me that you don't have a
lot of food small experience I have
little to none okay
once you get your air hockey show then
come talk to me back okay I have to tell
you you're the whole reason that I
started this show because we were eating
a meal on the road and you're like why
have you not done anything with your
first ball yeah it's a secret town that
that you had that I don't know why you
didn't use it yeah that's good I'm
working on your career as mine
diets in 2004 2004 2004
I like 2000 uh yeah
all right so this first game we're
playing we're just gonna play standard
game first person to five just let you
kind of like feel it out just just
everything object so you've got the
balls over there on your side okay just
no spinning that's the one rule no
spinning no spinning all right that was
my only move I had one move it was the
spin move all right you ready
I got her try to remember some of the
old tricks that I used to do when I
played my sister yeah oh the everybody
comes in oh how do you like that
hello D oh oh all right
I'm just feeling you out you know the
one thing I'd noticed about the show
right one how awesome I am but you're
much better than I predict - is there a
lot of dead time so do you have a lot of
comics sorry that's my house I let you
talk and then I just score here I'm show
producing before you score on there kind
of an ass from there all right okay all
right it's appendage on heparin soft
talk and then use lobby you just kind of
put it on was that was like pretty tight
for for just my you know whole like with
girls they're like is it is it him oh my
god you didn't even notice a little
butter down there a butter sticks all
you do that's called the Red Lobster
baby
coming in hot all right I played a Josh
wolf recently for the show and I beat
him oh that felt good go for it all
right
you know it was it was a good idea
however okay do not mention Josh wolf
ever again you hate him no you just I
just score it's and I'm jinx so I got it
okay okay so so is this one more two
more three two one
here we go I know your fears like
wondering why your strategies
you might want to like put your like
that put the feet up so that way if the
ball hits it it's more likely to go out
but if you have them back like this and
the ball hits it it's just gonna go in
yeah probably having the goalie in the
goalie position yeah good tip just just
just helping just being kind for a
second before I go back to shit-talking
okay here we go and go watch how fast
it's gonna happen
thank you literally like once it happens
wow I'm miss shot that one alright so
this is four two one
oh hey good D good D shoot a little
you're open good game okay stir them up
and we each take one good alright so you
got to start with two points just right
out the gate
you've got two points okay I have to
score three points on you within 60
seconds and if I don't have to play the
rest of the match blindfolded okay hey
you got so high so clean up to five I
get an extra two points off the back
right off the bat so I technically only
have to score three I've to score three
yeah and then you have to score three
within 60 seconds and if I don't have to
play the rest and that's why I'm folded
I've never had to play fully a blindfold
before oh this is intense okay okay so
you're gonna start with the ball god
this is gonna be hard okay except to
score three on you in 60 seconds okay
ready go
hey what no no no what if I stall like
this and they're not gonna get into 6000
nothing about that's an ass right there
that's dirty pleasure 3 yes
how fast was that 25 seconds without the
passive ever scored iron somebody
probably okay so now I don't have to put
vine folded but you still have you have
two points okay here we go
oh my god I thought for sure needs to be
replay somehow oh yeah yeah I'm
awkwardly getting more more mad than I
probably should
yeah you need one more any one more yeah
and then I got a scores three more yeah
before I square one more is you spin I
lose it's just us it's my words don't
trust me I'm gonna let you out have it
cuz I wonder I scored you think you
think you scored legally I don't know
but I'm gonna give it to you cuz it
looked good it was a very yeah alright
give me the ball I got it I just got to
end this now this is enough fooling
around
Oh Oh suddenly was he faking the whole
time oh oh that was
this is like a thing for you yeah like
when you say oh I'm good at foosball you
guys she's good at foosball and then you
actually play you and you go oh the
crutch she's actually really good at
foosball yeah it's a real thing and
should I be as gassed or winded as I am
right now probably not but I feel like
there's a lot of emotion happening for
you I think it was a little dancing this
move definite I've never seen up oh yeah
that's yeah hi so I came close to
beating there a couple times yeah I got
I got moves that she hasn't seen before
and it throws her off so I found a weak
spot I noticed that she gets when I
start moving like this and getting crazy
her brain just kick cuz she's enthralled
by my dancing and so I can kind of like
this like a snake charmer I can kind of
hypnotized her with just my my movement
and then ish and that's when I score I
was about to be very hurt that you were
gonna tell John what you think my
weaknesses are as a player because I've
never heard what you actually think my
weaknesses are do you do you have some
to talk about me I don't I don't
need the palm roll I need the palm roll
he needs the farm roll what's the palm
roll is it it's the way I know this
seriously sounds like a tutorial
so even though I beat you the first two
rounds you could beat me in this and
then you win everything perfectly that's
gonna happen I feel like everything you
do has just like dance moves like I
can't look at you oh
okay okay okay just this is so funny
that you're doing this now because
actually the punishment if you lose you
have to for 60 seconds straight boyband
it out with no music so just some music
in my mind just the music of your heart
okay so we're gonna play two ball so
that's where we each start with the ball
you have to score both balls to get a
point if you score a point I score a
point is just a wash and we go to three
points okay put it put it where you
please ready 1 2 3 that what's
cool that has never happened
I literally just scored both with one
motion yeah it was here I saw it wow I
am so good that was magic I'll
never be able to do that again
okay I'm taking off but I'm gonna call
on the palm roll thing I was
doing way better with the thumb and
grasping it like I have for 48 years
you started jerkin it six yeah look what
the math is wrong I won't judge okay one
two three
[Applause]
[Music]
so you can
come on so did you know I saw your
fiancee with a girl less oh wow
deep cuts shut down these lies
it's slander alright one more
it's two three whoa will you just give
yourself both so that's probably that's
knows weird is I actually face times
your mom before the show because we've
been seeing each other okay Dom the
reason why she moved closer this is
horrifying
I don't want to hear any of this so I
you're not allowed to speak to my mom
ever again ever ever again I don't want
to see you my momma say not a nice way
to treat your septa Oh No dance baby
okay where do I got a dancer can we put
60 seconds on the clock
pretty please 60 seconds is the only
time you got a dance all right okay so
you you want to call out the boy pants
yeah that's a good idea
I'll call a boy band okay ready okay
okay NSYNC Backstreet Boys oh yeah yeah
let the ladies know let the ladies know
about it what you gotta say oh I like it
98 degrees yeah it's in Nick Lachey
I see the Nick there maybe throw it up
to God if like there were a little
religious in 98 degrees maybe just like
praise up to a tip big baby J upstairs
yeah okay how about some Oh tom oh my
god this is an o-town I've never known
before I want some new addition you too
yeah Oh
that's your comfort zone look at you
sing in the words to it what's the one
that you like what Oh New Kids on the
Block you you have really nice stroke
mouth as you did I think is that we're
good Oh 60 seconds yeah gonna shake your
hand for those dancers that was a
beautiful thing lady that was awesome
you are awesome at this get better okay
come rematch when you have a ping-pong
table here yes where can people find you
online
oh right now I'll be getting an IV and
oxygen but after that John never calm or
Instagram is comedian John hi friend
perfect you can Spotify me have a bunch
albums bloodbath he's so funny
he's one of my favorite comedians I'm at
Kelsey Cooke comedy on instagram at
Kelsey cook on Twitter at Kelsey cook on
for tour dates and make sure you pick up
a risk of fury shirt that's awesome
your buttery I think you are also are
you the reason I have a risk of fury
shirt he just like my business manager
basis yeah it makes all my dreams
happens soon-to-be stepdad okay I just
threw up in my mouth I hate that hey
guys thanks for watching another episode
of risk of Fury be sure to pick up your
official Rissa fury shirt suppose 1985
foosball championships risk of Fury they
are so soft it feels like dolphin skin
your lovely make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and if you want a shirt just
click on the link below it's free
shipping